Ukraine захищає Європу і краще якщо ми
допомагатимемо зараз Україні ніж потім
іншим країнам
середла червону лінію переступила Росія
напавши на Україну
Ми не хочемо напливу росіян суди
долатвії
тому що саме російське суспільство має
зупинити агресію
[музика]
тепер це вже точно Німеччина надійшли
Україні основні бойові танки Леопард 2
Чи є у Вас якісь похвали адресу улафа
Шульца
Звичайно Це рішення канцлера Шульца дуже
вітається всіма союзниками НАТО
а також Латвії Латвія
Я вважаю що це правильне рішення бо
безпека Європи під загро
на Німеччиною особливо наула фашольца
чинився сильний зовнішній тиск на цьому
наполягали зокрема країни Балті чому
Тому що ми вважаємо що треба допомогти
підтримати Україну
Це єдиний спосіб захистити Європи
що Європа дедалі більше втягується у
війну у Європі та Німеччині чимало тих
хто виступає проти того що із заходу в
Україну надходить дедалі більше зброї Чи
розумієте ви їхню критику
Я бачу що ця критика не є обґрунтованою
тому що не надто не Європи не Німеччина
не Латвія є джерелом війни а Росія
звісно ми захищаємося
захист наших держав - це наш обов'язок
кажуть що Німеччина та нато послаблюють
самі себе відправляючи свою найкращу
зброю в Україну на заміну цих танків
Ідуть роки і не буде чим захищати країни
Балтії щоби про це думаєте
що це правильний аргумент
моя Росія втрачає своє озброєння
необхідно підтримувати Україну бо
повторюю Україна захищає Європи
якщо ми допомагатимемо зараз Україні ніж
потім іншим країнам
є інше аргумент постачання цих танків
означає для Кремля вихід за червоні
лінії і це може спровокувати Росію Надія
у відповідь проти Заходу що ви думаєте з
цього приводу
що згадка про червоні лінії доречно в
даному контексті
червону лінію переступила Росія напавши
на Україну
Україна яка бере на демократична держава
тобто Ви не боїтеся Скажімо так
наступного раунду ескалації між Росією
та заходом
ми маємо допомогти Україні захистити
націю державу
Росія має побачити що агресія не може
приносити вигоду
тому що якщо ми дозволимо Росії
отримувати вигоду за агресії і зрозуміло
які можуть бути обмеження
для Росії йти далі а також наприклад для
інших країн нападати на сусідів
лишній Президент Росії Дмитро Медведєв
нещодавно сказав що ядерна держава не
може програти Росія ядерна держава вас
не турбує перспектива атомної війни у
центрі Європи
нас немає ядерної зброї
і більшість європейських країн теж не
мають ядерної зброї
це Сполучені Штати і президент Байден
Уже сказав що застосування Росією
ядерної зброї в Україні буде катастрофою
для Росії
Німеччина вже витратила 3,3 млрд євро на
допомогу Україні це третє місце За
обсягом підтримки після США та
Великобританії але Латвія у відсотку у
Москві відношенні до ВВП підтримує
Україну навіть сильніше чи мають країни
західної Європи робити більше
якщо ми дивимося на геополітичну
ситуацію дуже важливо щоб Європа була
захищена
і тепер захист Європи перебуває в руках
України і наш обов'язок допомогти
Україні
Ваша країна разом з іншими країнами з
Балтії не лише закрила кордони для
росіян не для всіх але для більшості але
й однозначно відмовляється приймати
російських ухилянтів але ці люди тікають
від мобілізації і можливо навіть від
смерті Чому ви закриваєте свої кордони
для цих людей
ми закриваємо кордони для російських
туристів
якщо є реальний біженці звісно їхні
запити ми розглядаємо
Але ми не хочемо зараз на тлій ситуації
в Європі коли російські солдати вбивають
українців щоб до нас приїжджали
російські туристи
України
чи готові ви прийняти російських
ухилянтів які рятуються від мобілізації
Ми не хочемо напливу росіян сюди до
Латвії
тому що саме російське суспільство має
зупинити агресію
це аргумент звучить тут дедалі частіше
але реальність пана президента така що
люди в Росії які відкрито протестують
проти війни ставлять під загрозу свою
свободу і безпеку проти них порушено
сотні справ через якщо в Росії називають
дискредитацією збройних сил деяких з тих
хто протестував проти війни вже кинули
до в'язниці набагато років тож чи має ще
більше росіян потрапити за грати
Ми звичайно розглядатимемо окремі
випадки
але російських мігрантів наприклад
приймають у Німеччині
варто їхати до Німеччини але не долати
ми вже маємо російське населення
застерігали щодо російської агресії
особливо після анексії Криму у 2014-му
чи не здається вам що Західна Європа
західні країни не сприймали вас всерйоз
це серйозний прорахунок західних
політиків
він автоматично веде до повномасштабного
вторгнення в Україну
ми знаємо що це прямі наслідки і тому
саме з цієї причини ми виступаємо за
реальну підтримку України щоб вона могла
захистити себе цього разу
змінилося пане президентом чи стали
країна Балтії та їхня безпека більш
важливими та значущими для Альянсу Чи є
у вас таке відчуття
звичайно ми всі в Європі нині більше
думаємо про свій захист
бо маємо агресивного сусіда
Якщо у нас агресивний сусід то природно
ми підвищуємо нашу обороноздатність
президента Латвії Дякую за інтерв'ю
дякую вам